Uh,
okay.
So Islam part two.
Um,
I know there's a lot of new terminology,
new narratives.
Uh,
the things that I want you to keep in mind are what we're really gonna focus on
today.
And that is the Islamic conquest,
which certainly take place partly because of religious motivation,
but nevertheless are not,
not accompanied by some fanatical desire to convert the world.
Muslim conquests have to be understood in terms of religious motivation,
but not in terms of a determination to wipe out Judaism and Christianity.
What appears to be a paradox,
uh,
makes this era a little hard to understand.
Namely the paradox being that you would have such a rapid expansion of the Arabs
and the religion that they carried a which eventually would,
uh,
extend from Spain to India.
And at the same time that,
uh,
Islamic Islamic population would be a minority in most of those conquered
regions for centuries,
that there is not a demand for the conversion of the population to Islam.
And that although the conversion does take place in many,
even most parts of this imperial Califit,
it doesn't take place immediately and it doesn't take place under great
pressure.
I say apparent paradox because in fact,
the two things are different.
The motivation provided by the religion to conquer does not necessarily mean
that you require that everybody that you conquer embrace the religion.
Indeed,
in part,
this is because as Berkey emphasizes,
uh,
the distinctiveness of the religion was not worked out of four.
I mean,
it was worked out over the course of its first century beginning,
as we said last time in Medina,
but not fully articulated until the change of dynasty in seven 50 from the
Ommaya to the opposites.
Uh,
but the other reason is that there's no logical connection between conquest and
conversion.
It's perfectly possible to be,
uh,
a,
motivated conqueror and not to require that other people embrace your religion.
And this is for reasons that we'll say the other apparent paradox.
And,
and here,
you know,
I think it really is sort of a paradox is that the Islamic conquest are
accompanied by internal division within Islam.
Uh,
from,
uh,
six 50,
80,
by the time of the opposite succession that is a century later,
these two parties can be identified as Sunni and Shiite.
And you've read that and you're aware that this continues to be a division that
defines an awful lot of the Islamic world today.
It is particularly a problem in those countries such as Iraq for example,
that have both Sunni and Shiite populations.
It's not a problem in Morocco where,
uh,
everybody is,
um,
Sunni,
uh,
and it is less of a problem in contemporary around where a very large majority
is Shiite,
but,
uh,
um,
it is a,
it is a problem that defines both,
uh,
Islam as a religion and the politics of many countries to this day.
And so one of the things we have to talk about in,
in lecture entitled Islamic Conquest and Civil War is the origins of this split
within Islam.
The paradox is that the conquests keep on going even while it would seem that
religious unity is falling apart.
Now,
as you remember,
uh,
I hope,
after Mohammed's death,
there was no clear succession.
He didn't have a son and it wasn't clear.
One anyone would succeed to.
If he was the seal of the prophets,
then you couldn't succeed to prophesy.
Uh,
was he a religious ruler?
Was He military ruler?
Was he a judicial arbitrator?
His father in law are boubakeur who we saw was one of the first of his
followers,
um,
was elected college college meaning successor simply the succeeding two,
what was not defined,
but to some kind of combination of religious and secular rule.
As we said last time,
religious and secular rule are in a fundamental way,
not separate it in Islam,
although as we're going to start to see,
and as you've read,
uh,
there are some ways in which they do start to separate out,
particularly in the later,
uh,
in the up acid period,
boob boubakeur was elected.
That is the followers of Muhammad.
The people who were thought to have,
uh,
um,
some sort of original religious authority elected him.
His rival was Ali Ali,
the cousin of Mohammed and the son in law.
The same time of Mohammed Ali had married Fatima,
the daughter of Muhammad.
Okay.
But this election was not recognized by many of the tribes that had regarded
their loyalty to Mohammed as personal loyalty to Muhammad,
not to some institution and not to some permanent coterie of college or
successors.
So they refuse to recognize Abo backers authority.
And there ensued a,
what's called the Rida,
our Id d a or apostasy,
where the tribes rejected the authority of Alba backer and Boubakeur militarily
compelled them back into submission or recognition of his authority.
Although Bucca ruled for less than two years,
but he had already started on a key aspect of the reader be apostasy,
and that is turning the resistance to the apostasy into a war against external
enemies.
In other words,
the energy,
the military energy that had to be devoted to bringing these tribes back in once
they were brought in,
was continued to turn their military energies outward and outward means to the
north,
out of the Arabian desert and to the direct north and slightly northeast,
meaning Persia to the northwest,
meaning the Byzantine Empire.
And already under a boubakeur,
it was discovered that the Byzantine Empire and the Persian empire were hollowed
out.
And that what began as raids to keep these discontented tribes happy with a spot
of plunder turned into a conquest.
And as success breeds success,
and I don't think there's any more dramatic lesson of that Cliche,
the ambitions of the conquerors changed very quickly.
Well,
the ambitions of the Raiders changed very quickly from booty to conquest,
from plunder,
to,
uh,
a,
um,
expansion of territory.
Okay.
Remember that the Persians and the Byzantines had fought each other that in six
26,
Persia besieged Constantinople unsuccessfully six,
four years after the hug Gyra.
So from the Islamic Muslim Arab point of view,
the timing was great.
These two great empires had exhausted each other militarily and to some extent,
so spiritually as well.
In six 34.
In other words,
two years after the death of Mohammad,
the city of Damascus fell to the Arabs Damascus,
a capitol of Byzantine Syria.
Indeed,
one of the oldest cities in the world mentioned in the Bible,
in the Old Testament of the Bible,
uh,
a,
extremely important center of government commerce and a religion,
uh,
fel the Byzantine empire was defeated near Jerusalem.
Abo Balker died in six 34 and again,
Ali was passed over in another election in favor of another companion of
Mohammed Omar.
Another one of those original followers that we mentioned on the last,
in the last lecture,
Omar would rule from six 34 to six 44.
And he was a startlingly effective ruler in the 10 years of his collar fit.
The Arabs conquered the Persian empire entirely,
an empire that had lasted for centuries.
That had been one of the great,
uh,
world empires collapsed and,
um,
uh,
was taken over by Islam,
by the Arabs.
Okay.
The Byzantine Empire didn't completely collapsed,
but in this period at lost Syria,
Palestine,
and then its richest agricultural province,
Egypt.
Okay.
Alexandria capital of Egypt at that time surrendered in six 42.
We can list the factors that favor the Arab conquest though they're mostly sort
of favorable soil as it were,
not the plant itself.
Weakness of Persian Byzantium.
I've already mentioned a mastery of desert warfare.
We'll sort of see this a little bit with the Vikings at the end of the course
there are peoples who have been able to take advantage of an adverse environment
that they are able easily to swim through,
travel through a and that a less mobile,
um,
uh,
adversary a cannot deal with.
So,
uh,
the similarity between the sea and the rivers of Europe and the desert of the
Near East is that you can pick and choose your battles.
You appear off the coast.
Oh,
there's an army there.
We'll just go back and then we'll rate somewhere else.
The same is true.
The desert,
you appear out of the desert where the urban dwellers cannot easily field an
army.
And you discovered that there's nobody defending the city and you take it or you
discover there is somebody defending the city.
You go right back into the desert,
they can't pursue you there and you pick somewhere else.
So the mastery of desert warfare is in part a question of mobility and the Abl,
the ability to be able,
the ability to move in the desert freely,
easily.
And another aspect of the weakness of Persia and design team is the discontent
of their religious minorities.
Persia was ruled by a Zoroastrian elite and had other religious groups that
felt,
uh,
if not persecuted,
at least discriminated against.
And as we've seen,
the Byzantine Empire had a substantial Manava side population,
uh,
that were persecuted by the Orthodox.
These people might not exactly a fight for the invader,
but they certainly weren't unhappy,
uh,
when the invader showed up.
Indeed,
remember that I said that in a six 55,
there was a naval battle.
Um,
how could the Arabs have sailors if they hadn't seen a year round river,
uh,
until uh,
um,
you know,
a few years before this battle,
there sailors were many of them,
most of them from Manasseh office populations of Egypt in Syria,
we're able to recruit people who would fight for them,
uh,
who were not Muslim.
A third is the channeling of a warlike society towards external fighting.
If you,
I mean this is,
this is like a problem of conservation of energy.
You have a certain amount of energy that is being expended in external fighting.
If you can turn all those electrons or whatever in the same direction and make
them go outward,
uh,
they will be extremely powerful.
The limits of my scientific knowledge,
unfortunately,
uh,
you see displayed.
But you understand what I'm talking about.
That is the,
the internecine warfare has now turned outside because the plunder is better and
the motivation is better.
And then motivation is a fourth leak reason.
Religious motivation is this thing that is called a jihad,
right?
Everybody knows what this means and we're going to have to sort of grapple with
it because,
uh,
our understanding of it is,
um,
perhaps Parksville and distorted a jihad means struggle.
Uh,
it is a struggle against other religions or against other tendencies within
Islam.
There's plenty of energy,
um,
as we will see devoted to fights within Islam,
Internet scene,
religious fighting,
if not tribal feuding.
So we use the term jihad with some reservations.
It is wrong to think of the Arab conquest as an expression of jihad in the sense
that guys with knives in their teeth,
uh,
you know,
ride out and offer a terrorized population.
The choice of death or conversion.
Okay?
Once again,
it is possible to have a religious motivation
and yet not necessarily want to kill or convert the conquered people.
The Koran has plenty of information about the jihad,
but it is not completely consistent.
Certainly there is a sense that the unbelievers must be combated a sense of
martyrdom,
even that those who die in the struggle to advance the religion will receive
special favor.
But there is also a respect accorded to people of other religions in particular
Jews and Christians.
Okay.
And if you think about it,
it is psychologically possible to be convinced that God is following you.
God must be following you after all.
You just conquered Jerusalem.
You just conquered Alexandria.
You just came out of the desert and have um,
oh started to a role,
like a tsunami.
A,
an image that I don't think has really in the Koran,
well let's say role like the head,
the sands of the desert,
over ancient civilizations.
So God must be with you,
but the fact that God is with you may indicate that you were an elite and that
the people that you've conquered are simply going to stay that way or that if
they want to become Muslim,
that makes sense.
Obviously God favors Islam but they don't want to become Muslim.
That's their lookout.
So it does not mean that you have a hostile conquest policy.
Jihad is in this context not incompatible with tolerance.
Tolerance.
A word I use with caution as well because it's not as if they have a modern
ideal of tolerance of individuality of you have your religion.
I have my religion,
it is more that,
um,
uh,
they are not bothered by the
presence of people of other religions.
And we'll see some of why that is.
So number five,
a policy of allowing conquered people to maintain their religion,
livelihood,
and private lives.
So there are other rapid conquest in world history and there are other rapid
conquest by people who are technologically or culturally or certainly
economically behind the people that they conquer.
The Mon goals on goals conquer an incredible,
uh,
territory.
The Vikings,
which will end the course with,
are certainly less developed,
economically less civilized than the Carolingian Empire that they plunder.
What is unusual about Islam,
and I reiterate something that I've said already,
perhaps more than once,
is that it has a permanent effect rather than sort of disappearing back into
their yurts like the mon goals or disappearing back the,
uh,
Tundra.
Wow,
that's an unfair description of Scandinavia,
but disappearing back into the north like the Vikings,
the,
uh,
Islamic powers not only stay as occupiers,
but become themselves,
uh,
a,
a cultivated wealthy,
um,
highly civilized empire.
What is unusual about the Arabs then as their ability to consolidate and to hold
onto their conquest?
Okay.
I think I said before,
they're three startling things about Islam,
the career of Muhammad,
the rapidity and extent of the conquest and this business of the cultural
adaptability,
the consolidation of the Arab conquer rose
questions so far.
I think at the conquest part of this is clearer than the internal divisions.
So let's,
um,
proceed with the conquest rapidly.
There is no single regime.
There's no rule issued by the collar fed for conquest policy in general.
If the,
uh,
population surrendered on terms the way Alexandria had in six 42,
that was fine.
Then the,
uh,
people,
well we're allowed to keep their local customs.
In other words,
they were allowed to keep their houses,
their jobs,
their religion,
their property.
The Arabs were intent on plunder.
However,
why didn't they just pillage these people?
Uh,
some of it is,
um,
just wisdom that they do.
They're going to have to govern these places and that they might as well harness
the industry and enterprise of the population rather than kill them or disperse
them.
Some of it was,
I think that they had so much plunder available to them from other sources that
they didn't have to bother with.
Some,
you know,
middleclass artisans wealth.
They could plunder churches,
they could seize church lands,
they could take the state treasury.
Between them,
the state and the church held so much wealth that the Arab conquerors didn't
really want to bother with Mir private property
bleeding.
Nobles tended to flee.
They align their interests with the state.
They were very large property owners.
That land could be confiscated
and the reward to the congress was to be settled on lands of their own with
tenants of their own.
And these lands tended to have belonged to the state or to the church.
They long leases for these lands from the caliphate and they paid a religious
tax a kind of time as members of the Ooma,
the religious community and non Muslims were allowed to keep their property,
their land and other property,
but they had to pay two taxes that Muslims did not.
They had to pay what is called and it's called in the English speaking world,
a poll tax,
which is basically just a head tax.
Every person or every household pays a certain amount of money.
It's actually kind of like a flat tax,
but it has nothing to do with income.
It is simply that you as a person living in this polity,
pay this as a tax and then a land tax,
land tax,
obviously more variable and depending on how much land you own,
if you own x amount of land,
you pay a tax.
If you only ate x amount of land,
you pay eight times that tax.
At least that is the theory.
And given that,
as we said,
as far back as Diocletian,
you need to have very good records to keep track of taxes.
Then that kept on the old officials who had those records.
So the language of administration in Syria remains Greek for quite a while.
In Egypt it remains Greek.
In Persia it remains Persian cause the guys that are running it are basically
the same guys who were running it under the old empire.
Why would the Arabs want to get rid of them?
They'd want to get rid of,
you know,
the high officials,
the nobles,
but the functionaries,
the bureaucrats stayed on.
Most people who were Christians or Jews paid no more tax to the conquerors than
they had to the Byzantine or Persian empire.
In other words,
they were conquered.
Their lives did not radically change.
Their taxes,
did not go up.
They didn't really miss the Persian or Byzantine imperial regimes.
The question,
however,
is why are the Arabs so tolerant and this surprises people who assumed that
Islam has always been spread with a kind of a totalizing militancy.
In fact,
for a time,
the conquerors didn't encourage conversion because you can see the consequences
of conversion for taxation.
If 80% of the population is Jewish and Christian and 80% of the population is in
a high tax bracket,
if you are running things,
it's to your interest that they not convert to that very low 10% tax bracket or
whatever.
Those are caught the,
uh,
religious tax edge.
Go ahead,
have fun.
It's Sunday.
You know,
we'll go to church.
Don't bother me.
Pay Your taxes would be a fairly common attitude on the part of the concourse.
And of course there's a respect for,
uh,
Christianity and Judaism that I've already mentioned.
Some of it is confidence that eventually people are just going to see that,
uh,
Islam is a more successful,
up until the Abasand regime SevenFifty a vast majority of the conquered
territory remained in the religion that it had had before the conquest.
In other words,
in Egypt,
in SevenFifty,
a majority of the population were Christian and indeed in Egypt to this day,
10% of the population is Christian.
Okay.
Certainly Islam would gain,
and certainly now,
ironically,
much more than an 800 a d or 1200 a day or 1,580 or 1900 a d it's tough to be a
Christian in Egypt.
This is a problem of modernity,
not of the period we're dealing with.
So the process of conquest is very rapid,
but process of Islamization is not.
They're not to be confused
amidst all these triumphs,
the caliphate experiences divisions that culminated in a civil war,
civil war between six 56 and six 61.
And this begins,
or the origins of it seem to be the murder of Calif Omar in six 44,
he was murdered by a Persian Christian.
Okay.
So it's not a Muslim assassination,
but it ushered in another disputed election.
And Ollie poor guy presented himself yet again as the successor of Mohammed.
And again,
he was defeated this time by man with Mon,
we,
uh,
along with [inaudible] and Omar,
we mentioned him as one of,
okay.
The original followers of Mohammed Uthman was a member of a prominent clam,
the Oman.
Okay.
Hey.
Hi.
Status Mecca family.
Okay.
High status,
but the Umayyads had opposed Mohammed Uthman was a success,
an exception,
but his family were among those people of Mecca who had been the most,
uh,
steadfast in opposing this upstart guy.
So to some,
especially the followers of a lay with mon appeared to be a representative of a,
uh,
not really staunch Islamic family.
They were not fervent new followers.
Why was Ali passed over so many times?
It's not clear.
You're again,
we're in a very controversial,
uh,
area in which a lot of later tradition elaborates reasons for things that may
not have anything to do with what the reality was.
In,
um,
six 44,
you start to have pro Ali parties or traditions.
This is what would become the Shiite party and pro [inaudible] or pro califit
traditions that have the Sunni,
neither of which is completely to be relied on because obviously they are biased
under oath.
Mon,
the pace of conquest continues,
uh,
this naval battle and six 55 took place.
The Battle of the masts in which the Byzantine Navy was defeated by the Arab
navy.
Uh,
this meant that islands in the Mediterranean start to fall to the Arabs.
Cyprus was conquered in six 49 roads in six 54.
Meanwhile,
in the former Persian empire,
the eastern part of Iraq tending over towards,
uh,
um,
Persia was conquered in six 51,
six 53,
Armenia,
north and west of Persia,
uh,
east of Anatolia area where the earthquake was recently,
was conquered in six 53,
six 55,
but Guzman was particularly disliked by much of the population.
Unlike Omar,
unlike the early Caliphs,
he was regarded as lethargic and as a,
uh,
essential list,
let's say with our JIC and profligate,
a lover of luxury,
a monarch rather than a leader,
uh,
it corrupt rulers.
Okay.
And he was murdered by a Muslim in six 56.
Here we have the first assassination of a collar by another member of the
faithful.
Yeah.
And Ali was proclaimed as caliph.
The problem here is that Ali was proclaimed Colloff by the people who had
assassinated of Mon,
or at least he was perceived as taking the title from the bloodied hands of
assassins.
Whether he knew in advance of the plot against,
with mon is a doubtful,
but he starts off in a somewhat false position.
His collar off.
He's opposed bitterly body of Maya had family,
but more than that,
his claim to the caliphate is tarnished by the circumstances under which you
came into it.
And
no,
my Ed rose up against him and starts the first civil war of Islam.
This is our way up.
Yeah.
The governor of Syria who revolts in Damascus and leads a,
uh,
party against Caliph Ali.
In fact,
this gives rise to a militant group of people who hate both climates.
Ali is assassinated and more alia is wounded.
So I'm why were survives?
But the tendency within Islam to dispose of enemies by violent means has,
uh,
been sanctioned by the events of this period.
So six,
six,
31,
the civil war's over more are we are,
moves the capital from Medina to Damascus.
He establishes the Umayyads as a dynasty and they would rule as caliphs,
uh,
until seven 15.
What does this move from Medina to Damascus mean
was moved from,
it certainly is a part of the d Arab possession of the definition of the
caliphate.
Damascus is not an Arab city,
at least in its origin,
was part of the Byzantine Empire.
It is more centrally located than Medina in terms of administering the empire.
It's also more cosmopolitan.
It has a lot of different kinds of people.
So the move is a way from the Arab heartland to a place where the population is,
uh,
not necessarily Arab.
Okay.
It is part of the transformation of the caliphate from what we would call
religious leadership to that of a
kind of monarch king.
The college lives in a city.
He lives in a palace.
He has an immense entourage.
The days of the tents in Arabia or of quasar nomadic followers of Mohammed are
definitively over with the defeat of Ali defeat,
but it's not a complete defeat.
Shia means party
or to its opponents faction.
And for a long time the Shiites are like the perpetual losers who cannot at the
same time be eliminated.
They are a minority within Islam.
They are at various times seemingly overwhelmed by the wealth armies power of
the caliphs,
but they never go away and they never abandoned their claims.
They form the US eight permanent dissenting group within Islam.
Okay.
What is the nature of that descent?
What don't they like about Islam as it's practiced
by the majority in
any sense of that?
From this admittedly busy reading,
it's key that you understand what she is,
um,
is and what it's grievances are,
Spencer,
they reject the colleague as a religious,
they reject the Khalif as a religious figure.
Do they reject him because he's not the descendant of Valet?
Partly,
right.
I mean,
part of this is a succession question.
They reject the college because he's ill.
Legitimate.
So it's kind of like a dynastic question.
The only real caliphs,
and they don't use the term college,
they start to use the term emom is you've read
the only real religious leader is not the guy sitting in Damascus in his powers
with the position cliff splashing of fountains and you scented perfumes
everywhere.
Okay.
But to what extent do they re inject the caliphate as such?
Apart from the dynastic question,
how would you describe Shiite political theory
if the Sunni's are monarchical,
if they are comfortable with a colleague who rules over an empire of
unbelievable extent,
what might the Shiites preferred to see?
Okay.
It's been,
sorry.
Uh,
and something more informal indeed,
although I hesitate to use this term,
they are Republican,
Republican,
not in the 21st or 20th century American sense.
What does a Republican mean in this context?
Choosing representatives to then carry out the will of
yeah,
anti monarchical they regard the Caliph is sorta the George the third of the
Muslim world.
And I think don't want to have a single ruler,
uh,
who is at political ruler.
They're comfortable with rulership in at least some sense,
but the rulership should be either elected or inspired.
They are radicals in part because there dissenters there me out in part because
they are,
um,
they're really angry and they countenance violent tactics of opposition.
They are egalitarian and that's sort of what I mean by Republican.
It's not so much that they necessarily believe in a representative system
as that they believe in a system in which one class of believers is not exalted
over another and one person is not ruling merely because he comes from a certain
background.
Now what happens when religious movements are frustrated?
That is when they are objects of repression because indeed the Shiites worn,
not particularly tolerated by the college.
Often such religious groups become fixated on a future in which their claims
will be vindicated.
Ms Certainly
makes sense.
The Christians persecuted under the Roman Empire wrote,
but granddaddy of all prophetic texts,
prophetic of the destruction of your enemies,
the book of revelations,
I suggest that you take a look at that anyway as it's always interesting reading
and it is the book of the Bible that has the most relevance for better or worse
to the current world we live in because it's the one that talks constantly about
the future.
And what's going to happen is that future,
the apple computer future where everybody's wonderfully connected and we all,
you know,
can just float in some kind of,
um,
great brain that we participate in.
Or is the future some terrible ecological disaster in which will be,
you know,
cannibals and stuff or is the future the visitation of those angels,
those candlesticks,
those,
you know,
flowing rivers of molten metal and stuff.
As in the book of revelations,
we'll can we make trumpets all over the place.
Will,
you know,
one third of the population be wiped out one day and then another third the next
day.
And the narrator of the book of revelations cannot wait for this to happen.
It is in the nature of apocalyptic thinking that it is violent because your
enemies who are right now persecuting you are going to be confounded and they're
not going to be confounded in the,
Oh gee,
I'm really sorry I persecuted you.
Since they're going to be split apart and pulverized and you're going to be
watching and you're going to be applauding while they're split apart and
pulverized and torture.
That's the nature of mess.
Cyanic apocalyptic thinking,
apocalyptic meaning the end of the world in some kind of conflagration.
Cyanic meaning the presence of a savior.
The two are not the same thing,
but they tend to go together cause there's gonna be somebody who's going to come
and amidst the bloodshed in the fire,
a usher in a millennial world,
that is to say a world in which bad things have been purged and that Messiah may
be Jesus Christ at the second coming.
It may be the Messiah of Jewish tradition or in Shiite Islam,
it may be the mom,
the rightly guided in mom.
The Shiites has a leader.
I've just said that they're Republican and Egalitarian,
but they're not some kind of
occupy Wall Street.
We don't have any leaders and archaic group.
They have leaders,
but they are leaders who are inspired not,
I'm merely administrators have a huge bureaucracy and these moms succeed each
other and are recognized by the Shiite faction.
Okay.
Until the death of the 11th in mom,
the death of the 11th in mom without any obvious successor who is the 12th emom.
And we enter into this period of what the book calls occultation,
not a word that
you find used.
Well,
right.
It's got some sort of medical meaning to
occultation.
Meaning what?
Okay.
Oh,
come on.
This is in the reading.
He's gone into hiding occult means hidden.
There is a 12th and mom,
we just don't know where he is.
He's in a cave somewhere
and there are moms and moms after him.
Either he is deathless or he has,
there are other amounts,
but they're all hidden because they're not ready yet.
But when they are ready,
centuries of grievance are going to be uh,
uh,
revenge.
So there is a notion of a corrupt and misguided Islamic establishment
and of a true subterranean,
a cult
righteous level of um,
yeah,
uh,
of,
um,
the practice of the religion.
So she isn't,
tends to apocalyptic thinking to prophecy
is,
uh,
exalts Ali and his followers and it feels that it is in touch with the original
desert austere steer,
a galette Tyrian roots of Islam that had been corrupted by the monarchical
suspect purity of the Suni Caliphate who becomes a Shiite.
Yeah.
This is a hard question to answer because it is more than just a party or
faction.
If it was just a part of your faction,
it could not have lasted,
uh,
into the contemporary world with the force that it has,
who is discontent under Islam.
It would seem logical that the people who would be discontent would be non Arabs
because there is increasingly as the uh,
Islamic world takes shape a population of people who do convert to Islam who are
not Arabs.
We've said that the pace of Islam and hey was slow,
but nevertheless it was persistent and logical.
It's logical that people should have converted to Islam,
not only because it is a religion that to this day attracts lots of converts
because uh,
it has a religious appeal.
Uh,
and as I argued it is,
um,
it's a doable religion.
It's a religion that does not have a huge number of self.
Mortifying precepts is a way of living a righteous life in the world,
uh,
and performing certain duties that are not um,
tremendously honorous or very subtle and involve a lot of mental um,
uh,
internal dialogue.
So people are converting to Islam.
These people are known collectively as Marc Walley singular Marwan Marwan is a
non Arab Muslim in the early years sort of by definition a convert the day that
the mosque is fell,
there were no Muslims in Damascus except maybe for some Arab traders
as of the death of Muhammad.
All Muslims were Arabs.
But within decades of this with the conquests and conversion,
there are lots of non Arab Muslims.
They may need to learn Arabic to understand the Koran.
They're supposed to go to Mecca and so forth,
but they are not Arabs.
Are they equal to Arabs?
Well,
Arabs are always to this day going to feel themselves to have a special
relationship,
a special status should we say because Mohammed was an Arab and the movement
starts in Arabia.
But as I'm sure you know,
the largest countries from a point of view of population that are Islamic are
not Arabic almost at all.
Indonesia is the largest Muslim country in the world.
India is the second largest Muslim country in the world actually,
even though it's population is so large that Islam is a minority there.
Pakistan is the third largest,
I think,
uh,
these all our contribution without Arabs,
Iran is not Arabic.
It is,
as we all know,
an Islamic republic,
the w the world of Arabs is very numerous,
but the world of non Arab Muslims is more so,
and it is starting to become that way.
In the period that we're talking about was the Arabs are simply a small number
of concours and particularly in Persia,
uh,
where the pace of conversion is faster than that of say Egypt or Syria.
There are a lot of Milwaukee.
Okay.
At some point,
some of the benefits of conversion,
the fiscal benefits of conversion are eliminated.
Yeah.
Because the state,
the caliphate,
it can't afford to have a population that is only paying the low religious tax.
So it would seem that the moment at which you say,
okay,
we're happy that you're becoming a Muslim,
you're still paying land and poll taxes because we can't,
we can't actually aspire to make all Muslims equal from a fiscal point of view.
At that point you would have some angry,
my Wally,
at least.
So one would think,
and so one would think these would be prodo Shiites or she I recruiting grounds.
Okay.
There's a lot of debate about this Berkey kind of skirts over this issue.
Um,
other scholars doubt that this is the case.
They don't actually think that there's such a close connection between,
um,
the Shiite party and discontented people,
or at least there is a connection between the Shiite party and discontented
people.
But the discontented people are not discontent because of their tax position.
Okay.
The presence of discontent within Islam is a constant.
The presence of prophecy within Islam is a constant,
even though the teaching of the religion has been,
that is that Mohammed is the last prophet.
It's very hard to put a stop to prophesy in the Christian religion,
in the Jewish religion,
in the Muslim religion.
Once you have started to talk about inspired religious leaders,
uh,
they're going to crop up,
even after you've declared an end of a religious charisma and the consequences
of that and the splendor nevertheless have the opposite empire will form our
subject for the next lecture.